[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le point fort de notre liste et une
liste équilibrée diverses qui s'appuie à
la fois sur une génération de nouveaux
mais aussi d'anciens d'anciens élus dont
des anciens des adjoints actuellement
elle est issue des différents quartiers
elle s'est construite au fil de l'eau on
a rencontré un certain nombre de nos
colistiers au porte à porte et qui sont
qui leur ont donné leur aval et leur
consentement à intégrer notre liste le
développement du quartier gare bécane
parce que c'est lui qui nous apportera
un second souffle
c'est lui qui nous permettra de relancer
l'attractivité économique et de sortir
de l'ornière et de la prise de con est
enfermé avec les subsides de l'état
puisque on est un peu sous perfusion en
permanence sur cette commune donc il
faut donner une nouvelle impulsion à
celle ci et cela passe bien évidemment
par le projet gherbi cad qui est aussi
en lien avec celui du bois de les tempes
[Applaudissements]
elle sera à la fois d'aller trouver le
président de sky 1 pour discuter et pour
mettre en oeuvre rapidement ce chantier
gharbi cannes mais ça fera aussi d'aller
trouver l'inspection académique pour
leur dire nous étions en convention
académique de priorité éducative
vous nous avez sorti on a demandé
maintes et maintes fois y rester parce
que pour nous c'est nécessaire et c'est
important pour notre population c'est
important pour nos enfants et nous quand
nous irons voir l'inspection pour
demander à être de nouveau dans ce
dispositif d'accompagnement qui permet à
la fois aux enseignants d'avoir des
moyens supplémentaires et des ans aux
enfants d'en bénéficier
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]